Guten Tag, ich bin Dr. Gündo und in dieser Station als Assistenerstin tätig.
Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen heute ein Aufnahmegespräch führen.
Wenn Sie damit einverstanden sind, können wir anfangen?
Ja, können wir.
Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Manfred Böllhoff.
Können Sie bitte Ihren Vornamen und Nachnamen küssten?
Ja, Manfred schreibt sich M-A-N-F-R-E-D.
Manfred und der Nachname Böllhoff B-Ö-L-L-H-O-F-F.
Böllhoff.
B-Ö-L-L-H-O-F-F Böllhoff.
Böllhoff, ja.
Wie alt sind Sie, Herr Böllhoff?
Ich bin 67 Jahre alt.
Wie schwer sind Sie?
62, 69 Kilo.
69 Kilo. Wie groß sind Sie?
1,80 Meter.
Ja.
Und Herr Böllhoff, was kann ich für Sie tun? Was für Sie zu uns?
Seit zwei Tagen ist mir aufgefallen und meine Frau aufgefangen hat,
dass ich gelb bin im Gesicht.
Gelb geworden bin im Gesicht.
Und ich fühle mich in den letzten Tagen auch ziemlich müde.
Wenig leistungsfähig.
Und ich habe auch Juckreiz am ganzen Körper.
Juckreiz am ganzen Körper.
Haben Ihre Beschwerden vor zwei Tagen begonnen, oder?
Vor zwei Tagen bin ich gelb geworden im Gesicht.
Aber die Beschwerden, dass ich mich müde fühle und so,
das ist schon etwas länger.
Und mein Appetit ist in den letzten Wochen auch nicht so gut.
Das ist schon seit einigen Jahren.
Und haben Sie irgendwo Schmerzen?
Ja, ich habe Schmerzen.
So oben im Bauch und auch ein bisschen im Rücken.
Schmerzen haben Sie?
Können Sie bitte diese Schmerzen genau lokalisieren?
Ist es in der rechten Seite oder im linken?
Oder im Oberbauch?
Vielleicht im Oberbauch, mehr in der Mitte.
Und im Rücken ein bisschen mehr links vielleicht.
Wo genau diese Schmerzen lokalisiert?
Im Oberbauch oder im Rücken?
Vielleicht das kann im Oberbauch sein und Scherzalen aus dem Rücken.
Ja, es ist vielleicht ein bisschen mehr im Oberbauch.
Aber eben auch im Rücken.
Wie stark sind diese Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzkarne von 1 bis 10 vorbei?
Leichte und sehne und erträgliche Schmerzen sind.
Ich würde sagen 4 bis 5.
Und wann treten diese Schmerzen auf?
In der Ruhe oder bei Belastung?
Die sind immer.
Immer, ich schmeiße sie dauerhaft.
Es versteckt sich mit Bewegung oder?
Nein.
Nein, ist es meistens dauerhaft?
Oder gehen Sie auch wieder weg?
Dauerhaft.
Und gibt es bestimmte Auslöser für Ihre Schmerzen?
Ich habe keine Ahnung, ich habe keine Erklärung.
Kann ich nicht sagen.
Und ist Ihnen Übelkeit gefallen?
Ja, mir ist jetzt schon übel.
Seit gestern ist mir ziemlich übel.
Und ich habe auch schon zweimal erbrochen.
Und haben Sie Stuhlveränderungen des Urins aufgeteilt?
Ja, das ist mir aufgefallen.
Der Urin ist ziemlich dunkel.
Und der Stuhlgang ist sehr hell.
Und wie schlafen Sie, Herr Böhlhoff?
Oder haben Sie Schlafprobleme?
Nein, ich kann eigentlich ganz gut schlafen.
Ist Ihnen Fieber, Schüttelfrost oder noch Schweiß aufgefallen?
Fieber, Schüttelfrost habe ich nicht.
In letzter Zeit habe ich nachts etwas stärker geschwitzt.
Das stimmt.
Aber Sie haben keine Fieber?
Nein.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit Ungewohnte abgenommen?
Ja, das hat meine Frau gesagt.
Ich soll mich mal wiegen.
Ich habe in den letzten vier Wochen ungefähr sieben Kilo abgenommen.
In den letzten vier Wochen haben Sie sieben Kilo abgenommen.
Aber Sie haben keine Fieber.
Und ein bisschen Schüttelfrost.
Schwitzen, nicht Schüttelfrost.
Schwitzen.
Ist Sie schwitzen in der Nacht oder tagsüber?
Mehr in der Nacht.
In der Nacht besonders.
Und möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Oder gibt es einige noch Beschwerden, von denen ich wissen sollte?
Ich weiß nicht, was Sie wissen sollten.
Kann ich nicht sagen.
Ich kann jetzt nichts hinzufügen.
Ich bin getrunken.
Ich habe den Druckschmerz im Oberbauch und im Rücken.
Mein Juckreiz am Körper ist sehr stark belastend.
Sie haben einen Hartausschlag bemerkt?
Hartausschlag habe ich nicht.
Wie sind die Schmerzen im Laufe der Zeit?
Besser oder schlimmer geworden?
Die Schmerzen haben langsam angefangen.
Aber in der Stärke sind sie jetzt schon seit einigen Tagen.
Bestimmt seit zehn Tagen.
Zehn Tagen.
Haben Sie die Beschwerden früher gehabt?
Nein, das habe ich noch nie gehabt.
Können Sie bitte das Erbuch beschreiben?
Wie sieht das aus?
Das war so schleimig, gelblich.
Gelblich und schleimig.
Haben Sie Brutschpuren bemerkt?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Haben Sie Zollbrüne?
Nein.
Herr Berhoff, gibt es in Ihrer Krankengeschichte wichtige Erkrankungen, von denen ich wissen sollte?
Was meinen Sie für wichtige Erkrankungen?
Ich meinte vielleicht Bluthochdruck, erhöhte Blutwerte.
Seit ungefähr fünf Jahren habe ich erhöhten Blutdruck.
Und da nehme ich auch Tabletten für ein.
Seit fünf Jahren haben Sie gesagt, oder?
Ja, seit fünf Jahren.
Welche Tablette nehmen Sie ein?
Ich nehme da zwei verschiedene.
Einmal Rami-Pril.
Wie viele Medaillen?
Dahinter steht fünf.
Eine Tablette morgens und eine Tablette abends.
Dann morgens, da nehmen Sie eine oder?
Eine morgens, eine abends.
Eine abends, aha.
Und da nehme ich noch eine, Bisopolol.
Dahinter steht auch fünf.
Dann nehme ich auch eine Tablette morgens und eine Tablette abends.
Und Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie unter arteriärer Hypertronie leidet.
Gibt es noch andere Vorerkrankungen?
Vor zwei Jahren hatte ich einen Herzinfarkt.
Da wurden mir zwei Plastikröhrchen in die Herzkranz gefestigt.
Schüttern, das meinten Sie.
Und da muss ich jetzt auch immer eine Tablette nehmen.
Die heißt ASS 100.
Und Sie haben Bluthochdruck seit fünf Jahren.
Vor zwei Jahren wurde bei Ihnen eine Sternimplation durchgeführt.
Wie das genau heißt, weiß ich nicht.
Aber diese Röhrchen, zwei Röhrchen.
Das war bei dem Herzinfarkt, als ich den Herzinfarkt hatte.
Ja.
Gibt es noch andere Vorerkrankungen?
Nein, ganz nicht.
Und wurden Sie schon mal operiert?
Ja, als Kind, da war ich zehn Jahre alt.
Da hatte ich einen Nabelbruch.
Da wurde ich am Nabelbruch operiert.
Und mit zwölf Jahren an den Mandeln.
Und vor zehn Jahren, da war ich 57 Jahre alt, da wurde meine Gallenblase entfernt.
Weil da hatte ich Gallensteine und hatte auch Koliken.
Und dann wurde die Gallenblase entfernt.
Wann wurden Sie wegen Gallenblase operiert?
Vor zehn Jahren.
Vor zehn Jahren und vor zwölf Jahren?
Nein, im Alter von zwölf Jahren.
Als ich zwölf Jahre alt war, wurde ich an den Mandeln operiert.
Mandeln operiert.
Und regieren Sie auf bestimmte Medikamente allergisch?
Ist mir nicht bekannt.
Sie nehmen regelmäßig für unsere Prolole und ACCE ein und nehmen Sie bei Bedarf ein.
A.S.S.
Sonst nehme ich nichts ein.
Und gibt es aber keine anderen Medikamente?
Nein.
Und rauchen Sie?
Ja, ich rauche schon ziemlich lange.
Seit 45 Jahren rauche ich jeden Tag eine Schachtel.
Und trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, ich trinke so zwei kleine Flaschen Bier abends.
Und ich muss diese Frage stellen.
Aber haben Sie früher Kontakt zu Drogen gehabt oder konsumieren Sie Drogen?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Und Herr Berkhoff, gibt es in Ihrer Familiengeschichte bestimmte Erkrankungen?
Die Sie für uns fragen möchten.
Ach so.
Also mein Vater ist im Alter von 70 Jahren ist er an Magenkrebs verstorben.
Mit 70 Jahren? Magenkrebs.
Die Mutter lebt noch.
Die Mutter lebt noch. Die ist 88 Jahre alt.
Die hat Alterszucker und ein sehr schwaches Herz.
Das Herz pumpt nicht mehr richtig.
Und Ihre Mutter ist 88 Jahre alt und leidet an...
Alterszucker und Herzschwäche.
Haben Sie Schwester?
Ich habe eine Schwester. Die ist 64 Jahre alt.
Sie wurde vor einem Jahr an der Leber operiert, weil sie einen Leberkrebs hatte.
Und da wurde ein Teil der Leber entfernt.
Aber das hat sie, glaube ich, ganz gut bebehalten.
Vor?
Vor einem Jahr.
Und sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja, ich bin verheiratet. Wir haben zwei Kinder.
Die sind 40 Jahre alt und 38 Jahre. Die sind gesund.
40 und 38.
Und Sie beide sind gesund und leben Sie mit Ihrer Familie, oder?
Nein, nur mit meiner Frau. Die Kinder wohnen inzwischen woanders, haben ihre eigene Familie.
Und was machen Sie für mich?
Ich bin jetzt Rentner. Bis vor zwei Jahren habe ich als Elektriker gearbeitet.
Und haben Sie Haustiere?
Nein, keine Haustiere.
Und waren Sie in der letzten Zeit im Ausland?
Ich war im Sommer. Im letzten Sommer war ich zwei Wochen in Österreich.
Aber sonst habe ich meine Ferien in Deutschland verbracht.
Ich möchte noch etwas hinzufügen, Herr Bernd Boerhoff.
Tritten Ihre Beschwerden oder Schmerzen vor oder nach dem Essen auf?
Das kann ich gar nicht so sagen, weil ich habe in letzter Zeit auch wenig gegessen.
Mein Appetit war ja nicht so gut. Also das ist egal.
Die sind vor der Mahlzeit, nach der Mahlzeit. Ich esse zurzeit auch nur sehr kleine Portionen, weil mir das alles nicht so schmeckt.
Und ja, von meiner Seite war das alles. Als nächstes werde ich eine körperliche Untersuchung durchführen.
Und danach möchte ich Ihre Station mit meinem Chefarzt sprechen.
Und danach kann ich Ihnen eine richtige Diagnose stellen.
Und wir können später über Ihre Beschwerden nochmal sprechen.
Okay, das können wir so machen. Danke. Dann haben Sie jetzt einige Minuten Zeit.
Sie kennen das, sich etwas vorzubereiten, die Patientenbegriffe zu übersetzen in die medizinischen Begriffe.
Und Kolleginnen und Kollegen haben vielleicht noch Fragen.
Ja, ich kann eine Frage stellen.
Ja, aber die wichtigsten Fragen, finde ich, haben Sie schon gut gestellt.
Aber vielleicht gibt es noch Kollegen, die noch eine andere Frage stellen würden.
Dann bitte ich darum, dass Sie das tun. Es kann auch sein, dass für viele...
Das habe ich jetzt gerade nicht verstanden. Können Sie das nochmal sagen?
Das war ein Ton. Der Ton ist manchmal...
Haben Sie mir gefragt oder?
Gibt es von den Kollegen?
Darf ich fragen?
Ja, die Tonqualität ist irgendwie schwierig. Ich versuche sie zu verstehen.
Haben Sie Herzrasen, Büsten oder Herzkloppen?
Nein, ich habe keine Herzrasen.
Ist Ihnen schwindelig?
Nein.
Haben Sie Durchfall bemerkt?
Nein, Durchfall habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Die Frage wäre vielleicht noch sinnvoll gewesen. Auffälligkeiten beim Stuhlgang habe ich ja gesagt.
Die Stuhl ist hell. Vielleicht ruhig sagen, ist der Stuhl regelmäßig?
Ja, haben Sie da Auffälligkeiten bemerkt? Nein, der Stuhlgang ist eigentlich regelmäßig.
Nur, dass er in den letzten Tagen hell geworden ist.
Vorher war er normal gefärbt.
Bekommen Sie die Akkustik der Schweren?
Hatten Sie eine Ableitung gegen bestimmte Speise oder Essen?
Es tut mir leid. Ich kann das akustisch heute ganz schlecht verstehen. Versuchen Sie das bitte nochmal zu sagen.
Bevor die aktuelle Bekürzung anfängt, hatten Sie eine Ableitung gegen bestimmte Essen?
Ja, ich habe in letzter Zeit gemerkt, normalerweise esse ich gerne Fleisch.
In den letzten Wochen habe ich eher weniger Fleisch gegessen. Das ist mir schon aufgefallen, besonders meiner Frau.
Und auch frische Obst und Früchte habe ich in letzter Zeit auch nicht gegessen.
Vor allem die Schweren können sagen, dass sie Bluten für mich haben.
Bluten für mich.
Ich sehe die Schweren, die Bluten für mich haben.
Ich kann das akustisch nicht verstehen. Es tut mir leid.
Der Ton hat heute eine schwierige Qualität.
Ist der Schmerz gürtelförmig?
Der Schmerz gürtelförmig.
Vorne oben im Bauch ist der Schmerz und hinten im Rücken.
Auf der Höhe. Da ist er auch im Rücken etwas. Aber gürtelförmig nicht unbedingt.
Ich war bei dem Bewegen der Beschwerden noch nicht beim Hausarzt.
Ich gehe ungern zum Hausarzt oder zu Ärzten.
Ich wollte immer abwarten, aber es ist jetzt schlecht geworden.
Deswegen bin ich heute in die Klinik gegangen.
Weil ich so einen starken Juckreiz habe und weil ich so gelb geworden bin.
Ich lasse Sie sonst erst mal noch einige Minuten alleine.
Dann können Sie sich konzentrieren und dann können Sie bitte die Vorstellung machen.
Gut, bis gleich.
Darf ich eine Hilfe erhalten von meiner Kollegin?
Ja, aber er hat gesagt, dass er...
Frau Kollegin, können wir die Vorstellung machen oder brauchen Sie noch eine Minute?
Eine Minute brauche ich.
Okay.
Guten Tag Herr Chefarzt. Ich möchte Ihnen heute unsere neuen Patienten vorstellen.
Wenn Sie Zeit haben, kann ich anfangen.
Ja bitte.
Es startet sich um Herr Manfred Böllhoff.
Er ist 67 Jahre alt und 9,60 kg schwer.
Er ist 180 cm groß.
Der Patient stellt sich seit zwei Tagen eine harte Veränderung am Gesicht.
Und Oberbach schmerzt mit Schützralung auf den Rücken vor.
Okay.
Der Patient schüttelt.
Ja, stoppten Sie mal bitte gerade.
Herr Manfred Böllhoff ist ein 67-jähriger Patient, der sich vorstellte,
wegen einem seit zwei Tagen bestehenden Ictorus, aufgefallen im Gesicht.
Wahrscheinlich ist der Ictorus jetzt auch schon generalisiert,
vor, verbunden mit Abdominalschmerzen, überwiegend im Epigastrium, der Oberbauch,
und auch Einstrahlung nach Dorsal, in den Rücken nach Dorsal.
Was hat der Patient sonst noch für Symptome?
Er klagt darüber, Apathetlosigkeit und Gewichtverlust.
In den letzten vier Wochen 7 kg.
Er hat bemerkt, dass die Farbe dunkel ist und der Stuhl hell ist.
Hat der Patient Juckreiz?
Ja, er klagt über Juckreiz und Müdigkeit.
Wie ist der medizinische Begriff für Juckreiz?
Pyrrhuritus und Phartük.
Er hat zweimal erbrochen und seit gestern ist ihm übel.
Er klagt über Nausea und zweimal Emesis.
Wie sieht das Erbrochen aus?
Erbrochen sieht schleimig aus.
Der Urin ist dunkel verfärbt und der Stuhlgang ist hell.
Er hat einen Gewichtsverlust von 7 kg in den letzten vier Wochen.
Verbunden mit Inappetenz und allgemeiner Fatigue.
Können Sie etwas zu der Qualität der Schmerzen sagen?
Der Schmerz ist hell und wellenförmig dauerhaft.
Die Schmerzen sind langsam aufgetreten.
Die Schmerzlokalisation ist im Epigastrium und Dorsal.
Dorsal ist der Rücken und Epigastrium ist der Oberbauch.
Das hört sich nicht so gut an.
Ich kenne die Schmerzen.
Er leidet an arterieller Hypertonie seit fünf Jahren.
Er wird mit 5 mg morgens und abends behandelt.
Und sonstige chronische Abwesungen?
Vor zwei Jahren hat der Patient einen Herzinfarkt gelitten.
Kennen Sie den medizinischen Begriff für Herzinfarkt?
Sie kennen die Begriffe.
Sie kennen fast alle Begriffe.
Vor zwei Jahren hat der Patient einen Myokadinfarkt gelitten.
Er hat sich eine Standimplantation unterzogen.
Es wurde eine Intervention mit zweimaligem Stand gemacht.
Er nimmt deswegen noch Medikamente.
Er nimmt 100 mg in die Medikamente.
Eine pro Tag?
Ist der Patient schon einmal operiert worden?
Er hat seit zehn Jahren wegen der Nabelhernie eine Operation.
Kennen Sie den Fachbegriff?
Kennen Sie den Fachbegriff für die Nabelhernie?
Kennen Sie den medizinischen Begriff?
Genau.
Sie kennen die Begriffe.
Sie kennen die Medikamente.
Sie kennen die Operation.
Was gibt es noch für Operationen?
Vor zehn Jahren wurde eine Cholizistektomie durchgeführt.
Die Operationen sind die Nabelhernie, die Nabelhernie, die Cholizistektomie und die Tonsilektomie.
Gibt es Auffälligkeiten in der Familienvorgeschichte?
Ja, in der Familienanalyse besticht bei der Mutter Magenkarsenow.
Sie ist wegen Magenkarsenow mit 60 Jahren verstorben.
Wie alt ist der Vater?
Der Vater ist mit 70 Jahren an einem Magenkrebs oder Magenkarsenow verstorben.
Und die Mutter?
Die Mutter leidet an Herzinsuffizienz, Diabetes Melitus.
Die Mutter ist 88 Jahre alt.
Der Vater ist mit 70 Jahren verstorben.
Gibt es Geschwister?
Ja, die Schwester ist 64 Jahre alt.
Sie ist 64 Jahre alt und wegen Magenkrebs wurde bei ihr eine Operation durchgeführt.
Vor einem Jahr wurde eine Leberteilresektion durchgeführt.
Bei Leberkrebs, man kann eventuell sagen Hepatozelluläreskarzinom.
Es war ein bösartiger Tumor.
Es war ein Neoplasma.
Die Schwester operiert.
Wir haben in der Familienanalyse schon Auffälligkeiten.
Wir haben den Vater, der an einem Magenkarsenow verstorben ist.
Wir haben die Schwester, die an einem Leberkarsenow oder Neoplasma operiert worden ist.
Gibt es sonst Auffälligkeiten bei den Risikofaktoren des Patienten?
Rauchen der Patienten, Trinken der Alkohol?
Ja, seit 45 Jahren.
Ein Schachtel am Tag.
Und trinke zwei kleine Flasche Bier am Abend.
Es besteht ein erheblicher Nikotin-Abusus von 45 Packages.
Jeden Tag ein Paket, ein Päckchen, 45 Jahre.
Und zwei Flaschen Bier.
Da haben wir jetzt ja einiges zusammen.
Was ist denn jetzt Ihre Verdachtsdiagnose?
Die Anamnitische-Angaben deuten am ersten auf Pankreas-Karsenohm.
Und die Diagnostik kommt ...
Ja, ich weiß nicht. Vielleicht Kolonkarsenohm kann sein.
Aber Kolonkarsenohm in Beziracht.
Also ein Pankreas-Karsenohm oder ein konsumierender Neoplasma muss man befürchten.
Der Patient hat eine sehr rasche Gewichtsabnahme.
7 Kilo. Er hat nicht so eindeutige Schmerzen in Richtung einer Pankreatitis.
Er hat die Schmerzen noch nie richtig im Vordergrund.
Das spricht schon alles für einen Pankreas-Tumor.
Der dann den Gallengang verschließt und zu einem Ictorus führt.
Pankreas-Karsenohm in diesem Fall.
Das spricht alles dafür.
Es spricht dafür der Schmerz im Epigastrium, Dumpf und die Ausstrahlung nach Dorsal.
Das ist eigentlich auch für einen Pankreas-Prozess nicht ganz typisch.
Aber es trifft oft zu.
Das ist schon so.
Die Gallenblase direkt kommt nicht in Betracht.
Der Patient ist schuletisstektomiert.
Vielleicht kann er eventuell noch ein Julidochus-Karsenohm haben.
Oder im Bereich der Leber auch natürlich etwas.
Aber es spricht viel für einen Pankreas-Kopfkarzenohm.
Da spricht einiges dafür.
Es ist ja auch nur eine Verdachtsdiagnose.
Sie sollen jetzt die richtige Diagnose nur aufgrund der Anamnese stellen.
Sie müssen ja auch noch körperlich untersuchen.
Aber die Anamnese ist ein sehr wichtiger Baustein dafür.
Erst mal vielen Dank.
Was mir aufgefallen ist, Sie können ganz viele Fachbegriffe, medizinische.
Sie müssen sie gebrauchen.
Sie müssen sie einsetzen.
In den Berichtern für den Oberarzt.
Wenn der Patient vorgestellt wird, dass Sie wirklich möglichst die medizinischen Begriffe auch nennen.
Und dafür haben Sie etwas mehr Vorbereitungszeit natürlich in der Prüfung.
Am besten markieren Sie sich den Begriff Übelkeit.
Wie erbrechen Sie das?
Nausea, Emesis, Epigastrium, Dorsal.
Und dann wissen Sie, weil Sie alle die Begriffe kennen.
Hier gibt es noch ein Differentialdiagnose.
Duodenalkarsenohm.
Das kann auch ein Tumor der Papillaeufateri sein.
Eingang ins Duodenum zum Beispiel.
Natürlich kann das auch eine Rolle spielen.
Das wissen wir nicht genau.
Aber wenn Sie da eine Differentialdiagnose nach der Verdachtsdiagnose nennen,
dann ist das denke ich erst mal ausreichend.
Sie müssen nicht vier oder fünf verschiedene Differentialdiagnose nennen.
Und die Verdachtsdiagnose muss nicht immer korrekt sein, aber in die richtige Richtung denken.
Haben Sie gemacht. Sehr gut.
Danke erst mal.
Haben Sie einen Prüfungstermin?
Ja, ich habe nicht viel Zeit, aber ich weiß nicht, ich kann das verschieben.
Warum?
Ich fühle mich nicht so vorbereitet.
Dann kann man das immer wieder verschieben, weil man immer noch nicht perfekt ist.
Aber ich finde das haben Sie gut gemacht.
Sie müssen sich nur ein bisschen erinnern, übersetzen.
Sind Sie systematisch in die Fachbegriffe.
Dann sehe ich da überhaupt kein Problem.
Wann ist denn Ihr Termin?
Nach zwei Wochen.
Versuchen Sie das. Und wo ist das? In welcher Ärztekammer?
In München.
In München, ja, komm. Das kriegen Sie hin.
Mit der nötigen Entspannung, das ist nicht so einfach, ich weiß.
Aber Sie schaffen das.
Danke schön.
Ich werde alles in diesem Wochenende wiederholen.
Aber nicht zu lange am Stück.
Wir wissen, wenn Sie das mehrere Stunden am Stück ohne Pause machen,
ist das fürs Gehirn nicht gut.
Sie müssen zwischendurch spazieren gehen, sich entspannen, einen Tee trinken.
Alles gut.
Gut, dann wünsche ich Ihnen noch viel Erfolg bei der Verwaltung.
Wir können uns gerade an den Moderator nächste Woche Donnerstag um 18 Uhr wiedersehen.
Wiedersehen.
Ist das okay?
Gut, dann wünsche ich Ihnen einen schönen Abend und machen Sie es gut. Tschüss.
Tschüss.